Einige von euch haben sicher mitbekommen großbritannien wurde wieder ein paar mit dem nervengift namens novacek vergiftet die frau ist nun gestorben
verantwortlich dafür ist dieselbe substanz wie bei dem anschlag auf den doppelagenten street war vor einigen monaten feststeht
nowak ist hochgiftig und tödlicher als das nervengift sarin
niemand weiß wie es überhaupt nach großbritannien kam also ein hochaktuelles thema mit vielen offenen fragen was ist das genau für ein stoff wie
wirkte auf den menschlichen körper und besteht auch die gefahr für die gesamte öffentlichkeit hierbei klick zum science fiction jetzt die antworten herzlich willkommen
Es dauerte nur wenige stunden und dann stand auch hier sicher fest der
45 jährige mann und seine 44 jährige frau die mann bewusstlos in einem wohnhaus in der nähe des britischen sainsbury
gefunden hatte waren mit dem nervengift nowak vergiftet worden das passiert über die atemwege und manchmal auch über die haut oder
schleimhäute im menschlichen körper
blockiert nowaczyk ein enzym das
eigentlich für die kommunikation zwischen nerven und muskeln zuständig ist die folge eine überstrapazierung der muskeln was sich in krämpfen
äußert mann leidet an kopfschmerzen durchfall übelkeit und atemnot
und im schlimmsten fall kann es auch zu herzstillstand und bewusstlosigkeit kommen das gehirn kann durch den sauerstoffmangel
geschädigt werden mit langzeitfolgen ob man als opfer eines solchen
anschlages überlebt hängt stark davon ab wie schnell ein gegenmittel gegeben werden kann dass das blockierte enzymen wieder
reaktiviert die beiden opfer aus salzburg jedenfalls schritt lange zeit in lebensgefahr die 44 jährige frau ist nun gestorben
und die behörden in großbritannien ermitteln nun wegen mordes
sofort werden erinnerungen wach an anfang märz vielleicht hatte er es mitbekommen damals war ein anschlag mit diesem
nervengift auf den ehemaligen russischen doppelagenten sergej skripal und seine tochter julia verübt worden
großbritannien und auch viele andere politiker gaben damals russland die schuld liegt ja auch eigentlich auf der hand unabhängig davon
kämpften die beiden damals wochenlang im krankenhaus um ihr leben jetzt also der zweite mysteriöse fall und das ganze in der nähe des
wohnorts der ersten opfer ob das nervengift aus derselben charge
stammt wie bei den skript als ist allerdings noch nicht bekannt fest steht
die so video nun hat die naughty dog gifte in den 70er und 80er jahren entwickelt gegen ende des kalten krieges und
niemand sollte davon wissen um
internationale abkommen zu waffen zu umgehen sollten ovi job so entwickelt werden dass diese substanz nicht nachweisbar ist
aktionen kamen dann anfang der 90er jahre
doch ans liegt aber nur bei zwei chemiker davon berichtet nun noch immer lassen sich diese stoffe nicht so einfach nachweisen wie es bei anderen
nervengifte der fall ist wie beispielsweise sarin und vx zwei hochgiftigen substanzen übrigens wie auch durch bloßen kontakt und das einatmen
innerhalb von minuten zum tod führen
nervengifte heißen sie deshalb weil sie das nervensystem wie new york leben und so diverse körperfunktion
erheblich stören und so lahm legen
so dass die opfer sehr schnell sterben doch nur wie doc hat es in sich die gesamte gift gruppe besteht aus etwa
100 verschiedenen stoff varianten von denen manche bis zu acht mal tödlicher sein sollen als das nervengift
vx sie sind sehr feine bruder und wirken den menschlichen körper
langsamer im gegensatz zu vielen anderen
nervengifte die als kampfstoffe oder waffen eingesetzt werden das sind meistens farblose flüssigkeit in den halb weniger minuten zum tod führen
kurioserweise wird das gift nowak aus zwei stoffen hergestellt die an sich nicht giftig sind seine tödliche wirkung
entsteht erst bei der kombination bei der grundstufe werden nicht besonders streng kontrolliert und können theoretisch
leicht geschafft werden expertinnen und experten sind der ansicht dass die kombination der beiden stoffe allerdings für einen laien nicht möglich sei
dafür sei ein gewisses fachwissen
notwendig dass beispielsweise geübte chemiker und chemikerinnen haben so
wird behauptet andere experten und experten glauben dass nur staaten dazu fähig sein denn schließlich seien labore mit sehr hohen
sicherheitsvorschriften
voraussetzungen jetzt bei dem aktuellen zweiten fall sind sich die britischen behörden relativ sicher dass die beiden opfer nur
zufällig mit dem giftstoff in berührung haben und sie eben nicht gezielt mit naughty dog angegriffen wurden dennoch steht die große frage im raum
wie sie sich kontaminiert haben können nach dem anschlag am skript wahl wurden neun bereiche in der region
dekontaminiert für millionenbeträge
an seiner türklinke hatte man im frühling die höchste note job konzentration festgestellt doch wie diese genau
kontaminiert worden war also wie das gift dorthin kamen das weiß man nicht ein behältnis oder ähnliches wurde bisher nicht gefunden damals wie heute
sehen die doch keine große gefahr für die bevölkerung
doch gegen das mulmige gefühl dass bei vielen briten bleibt hilft diese
einschätzung nicht offen bleiben weitere fragen woher stammt die substanz und wo wurde sie hergestellt mit den heutigen
labormethoden ist es möglich durch
verbliebene reste rückschlüsse darauf herzustellen denn die staaten wissen etwa durch welche prozesse die
unterschiedlichen regierungen solche substanzen herstellen russland hat ja ende des letzten jahres
2017 bekannt gegeben an der letzten gv waffen zerstört zu haben das nachzuprüfen ja das ist jedoch reichlich schwer die
ermittlungsbehörden arbeiten aber
intensiv daran herauszufinden
woher das gift stammt wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollen dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte hamburg sie auf youtube
und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen andern vom neues video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal pixum social and media abonnieren da gibt es
immer das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber natürlich nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
nieper das gefährlichste virus der welt breitet sich in indien aus bis dann
bleibt dran